المستقبل بعد ما ضاع 30 سنه من من يعني من
هذا الوقت الثمين اللي اي ابن بقضيه مع
والدته المستقبل الان قديه رح تلتقوا قديه
راح تقدوا اوقات مع بعض حتى نعوض السنين
اللي فاتت
ان شاء الله هذا شيء اكيد وان شاء الله
اني بحاول اني اجيبها للسعوديه عندي واروح
لها واجي يعني هذا الشيء بحاول اني اعوضها
عن كل اللي فات والله يقدر ان شاء الله
واسعدها ويخليها لي ويطول بعمرها يعني هذا
الشيء اللي كنت او من بدايه حياتي وهو
ناقصني انه وجود امي جنبي ووجود حنانها
وعطفها علي
ما شافتني وانا كبرت وانا صغير كل جميع من
مراحل عمري حتى لما تزوجت كنت اتمنى انها
تكون معي موجوده بعد ما ربي رزقني بمولود
مره احتجت اني اوصلها باي طريق باي وسيله
من الوسل فما جاء في بالي والله الا
السفاره السعوديه
والحمد لله والله كلهم ما قصروا واشكرهم
كلهم من على راسهم السفير اسامه نقلي
وجميع العاملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات